When you play music--
[PLAYING GUITAR]
--you're bringing light
into the darkness.
[DRUMMING]
I want to teach
because I love watching
humans unfold their wings.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're here to get
people's attention.
I'm giving you reference
to an attitude.
Some people will say,
what kind of pedal
is that, or what
kind of strings,
or what kind of guitar,
or what kind of amplifier?
No, it was soul, heart,
mind, body, and your vitals--
one note.
And with that note,
people go, whoa!
[PLAYING GUITAR]
If you don't stand like that, it
ain't going to sound like that.
Before you put your
fingers on the fret,
visualize these strings from
your eyes to your heart.
And then you play.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
Whew!
Watch out, world!
[MUSIC - SANTANA, "OYE COMO VA"]
The real musicians
make the ugliest
face to create the
most beautiful note.
They're leaving Earth,
and like, the gravity
is pulling their
face like, raaggh.
And if your face don't show
that you're making an effort,
then you're not going
to touch the listener.
[MUSIC - SANTANA, "OYE COMO VA"]
We tend to look for greatness
always in somebody else rather
than yourself.
Go inside and get your sound.
You can only go into
the heart by you
being vulnerable yourself.
That's a whole other
level of musicianship.
[PLAYING GUITAR]
Hoo!
I'm Carlos Santana.
This is my MasterClass.